Hello and welcome. It's January 26,
2023. We're here in active inference
model stream number 8.1. Today we're
appreciative to have Thomas Ringstrom,
who will be presenting on Reward is Not
Necessary, a compositional theory of
Self Preserving Agents with Empowerment
gain maximization. There will be a
presentation followed by a discussion.
So Thomas, thank you for joining.
Really looking forward to this. Off to
you. Yeah, thank you very much.
It's really nice to be here and talk to
this group.
I'm a computer science PhD student at
the University of Minnesota. My
interests are in what
are the computational properties that we
would need to have agents which
flexibly plan in sort of high
dimensional product spaces of variables,
and also how do we get agents to perform
complex tasks in an intrinsically
motivated way, especially in high
dimensional product spaces.
So this presentation
is going to argue that reward
I know I'm talking to a sort of active
inference crowd, but some
of the same points apply to active
inference perhaps too. But this
presentation is mostly about how there's
going to be some major problems. I think
using reward maximization objectives,
and by moving to sort of reward free
objective functions, we can get really
nice factorizations that help us plan.
So let's just start off with a sort of
simple, picture simplified picture of an
organism. So we have a honey badger
here.
This honey badger has internal
states. It gets hungry and it gets
thirsty. And there's also an external
world that the agent lives in.
And in order to sort of modify internal
state spaces, the agent might have to
perform some complex tasks.
It might have to get several items in
order to eat an apple or things like
that. So you could see that maybe some
symbolic state space sort of mediates
the connection between things you do in
the world and transformations that you
make on some internal state space.
And of course, real world organisms
and humans live in a high dimensional
world. So you could imagine that there's
an encoder and a decoder and really
there's a sort of high dimensional
physiological or interoceptive domain
that is these Y tilde
with the dot or Y tilde, I should say,
and Z tilde. And then there's a high
dimensional world. You could just say
that's x tilde. And really you just need
to sort of map these down to some
discrete state space in which these
domains can interact here's
like a simple encoder and decoder.
If an agent has a kind of
simple ontology like this, you can
imagine that it's sort of generatively
entrained to the world that it lives in,
which is a notion that's probably pretty
familiar to sort of active inference
people. So you have some
encoder of these high dimensional states
and then you have some operator PS,
which is in the middle of the head here.
And that just sort of advances the
latent states. And then you decode and
you'll get sort of expectations of the
high dimensional world that the agent
lives in.
The problem is that you can't really
represent explicitly these latent
space transition operators that would
dictate the dynamics of all these
variables. You can't represent it as an
explicit object because the more state
spaces that you keep track of in the
world, the larger this object
PS becomes. So in order to
handle this, you'd have to represent it
in a sort of factorized form. So you
just would represent its factors. You
wouldn't explicitly sort of enumerate
all of the state vector transitions
under this transition operator. And so
what we really need to think about is
what are the sort of model based or the
sort of bellman principles for
decomposing hierarchical state spaces
so that we can create the right
representations that help us plan in a
flexible way in a sort of time varying,
time dependent world of lots
of variables. So this just means what is
a sort of objective function l
calligraphic L applied to PS or its
factorization that would
give us some factors here ada
and these omegas that could help us
plan. And also,
given the fact that the state space,
the effective product space that we're
working in is so large and there's many
possible state vectors that describe
possible states of the world, how do you
know what to do? I mean, if you're an RL
theorist, you would have to say, well,
there exists some kind of reward
function that tells you this
state of the world is worth this much
reward and this state of the world is
worth this much reward. But it's not
really clear how you should define
reward functions on huge product spaces.
So I will address this question from
sort of reward free perspective.
And just to give you a hint of what it's
going to be like, what I'm going to
argue is that what we really need
are agents that have a kind of
structured core ontology that it needs
to maintain. That is coupled state
spaces that really depend on each other,
in which the policies that you use
maintain the sort of internal integrity
or controllability of the agent.
And that's where empowerment will
eventually come in. So I'll talk about
empowerment a little too. That's the
controllability metric. So here
I'm just saying what's a nice policy or
what's an objective function f that
takes in some intrinsic motivation
function, which is this fancy V here,
along with a nice factorization that
allows you to plan in the world. Okay?
So just to recap things that I already
said, we're in a product space of
state of variables. We have internal and
external state spaces, hunger and
hydration state spaces can be dynamic.
As you do things in the world, you get
hungrier. So how do we plan?
How do we know what a good goal is? And
what I'm going to argue is that we
should compute a specific representation
called a state time feasibility
function, which is going to be an
abstraction that's going to map us from
initial state times to final state
times. And this will have some really
nice properties that allow us to sort of
reason in this high dimensional state
space. And I'm going to talk about this
from just a dynamic programming point
of view. There isn't going to be any
learning. Okay? So let's
just talk about transition operator
composition, because I said, well, we
have this large product space of state
variables and it'd be nice if we just
represented it as a factorization. So
what does that mean? So imagine that
you have PX, which is like a base state
space to move around the world, and you
have some internal state space or
secondary state space PY. And these are
linked by some function f. So here's
your base state space. And here's the
honey badger in the state space.
And here's the secondary state space,
which is just like your internal hunger
space. And so F,
what F is going to be is called an
availability function. And an
availability function is going to say,
oh, this honey badger is in state XAT
at time T. And given that it's there,
what's the probability that this goal is
available from this state time,
state action time. And so this goal is
formally going to be an action on the
higher level state space. So for
instance, these green lines on the high
level state space are going to map you
to the most satiated state
where you're not hungry anymore at all.
And then these black lines on the
internal state space are just going to
decrement you one state if you're not at
the tree, so you eat apples at the tree
and that's going to map you to the top.
And all other states without a tree,
you're going to get hungrier over time.
Okay, so if we wanted to write a product
space operator PS y prime, x prime,
we can just represent this as a
composition where lambda P is our
composition operator, and it's just
going to be defined as the product of
your two state spaces with F linking
them. And then we sum over G. So we're
getting rid of the goal variable and so
we can represent the
product space this way. And we can also
just call the product space. We can say
that bold S here is just the state
vector for yx, or if we have more
variables that can be incorporated into
bold S. Okay, so what
if we have more features of the world?
We can drink water, we can get warm at
the house. Well, we will need
to have a bigger composition.
So we can just create an operator called
we'll just call PR, where bold R is
just state vector of w y and Z, and w y
and Z correspond to the hydration,
the hunger, and the temperature space.
And so this is just a product of the
individual ones, individual operators.
And so this influence graph is
connecting PX to Pwpy
and PZ through F. And so we can just
define the product space operator as
a composition this way. And if we do
that, you start to realize, well, this
is nice because the effective state
space exponentiates essentially
as you add on more state spaces that you
can control. And so this influence graph
is just showing what is the sort of
ontology of the agent, what constitutes
it as its internal and external
coupling. And you could imagine that it
gets more complicated, for instance,
that if you hit W zero or
Y zero or whatever,
these skull and crossbones indicates
that you die. So you can imagine being
in a state has a bi directional
influence. So Zeta here is
conditioning the possible dynamics PX
can produce. So you could imagine that
once you're in one of those sort of
defective bad states that it kills you
and you can't move around. So you could
imagine sort of more complicated
structures like this, which essentially
mean that you have to go out in the
world and do things in order to keep the
system alive. So you don't want to hit W
zero or Z zero. And you can
imagine this gets even more complicated.
You could compose sort of larger
structures where P sigma is going to be
some logical state space that keeps
track of multiple conditional events
that need to occur for say, eat an
apple or something like that.
So representing it in this form is very
nice. We just represent the factors and
the links between the state spaces and
that's a sort of memory efficient way
of representing the space.
Okay, so if we have a homeostatic task,
I'll eventually get to the sort of
Bellman equations and the model based
formulas. But first I'm just going to
sort of build up an intuition in
the form of an example about how these
state time feasibility functions are
going to work. The state time
feasibility function being the
representation that I'm arguing for in
this talk. So if we have a hiker
and it can go out into the world and
drink and eat and get warm with these
goal variables, well, there's also this
goal variable, G epsilon, which is going
to decrement by
one state. Then as
the hiker moves around,
you could represent this as a function.
So imagine that the hiker starts at xg
one, that's the house, and TS,
which is the start time, and the hiker
follows a policy pi two. So imagine that
you have a policy that is like a goal
condition policy pi G two that's going
to take you to xg two. Okay? So it's a
policy, it's like a shortest path policy
or whatever, then that means
that there's going to be some final
state time xg two TF that you
achieve this goal G drink, which
remember is in action on the higher
level space.
So what this would look like is that you
decrement two, right, because that takes
two time steps to get to the lake. And
then once you get to the lake, you take
the state action that's going to drink
and it's going to bring you up. So
there's three total steps in this
process of inducing
the drink goal variable and then the
step after drinking,
which would look like this. And then you
can imagine the other state spaces are
not involved and so they will all
decrement three because there's three
time steps. And so one
way to represent this is to realize
that if all of these sort
of goal variables on the way to the
lake are sort of the null goal
variables, meaning that the agent isn't
affecting some other state space, then
you can define that as a Markov chain.
So if you set all of the goals
to be the epsilon goal, the null
goal, then this PY epsilon
is going to be a Markov
chain matrix. And so that means that
the time difference encoded
in the state time feasibility function,
the TF minus TS is going to be the power
that you can take this Markov chain to
in order to forward evolve all
the other internal state spaces. So you
can define an operator that does this in
one step called Omega Y, which is just
going to take some initial state. So
this green dot or this red dot,
and it's going to take the time
difference. So this is going to be two
to get from the house to the lake. It's
two time steps. And so these gray arcs
are just an initial to final state map
under this policy.
And so what this looks like,
this looks sort of complicated, but you
can build a jump operator that jumps you
from your initial high dimensional
state. For instance YXT.
And we're just considering Y for now. I
don't have the other state spaces W and
Z in here, but this Ada
over here is mapping you on the X space.
The Omega Y is mapping you forward in
the Y space and then the PY and the PX
are just evolving by one step to
update after you hit the goal. So after
you hit the goal, you have to update by
one step. So PY and PX do that for both
state spaces and then of course you
can do this for all of the state spaces.
So a jump operator for all of the
internal state spaces, r, where R is
remember, is the vector of all your
internal states w, Y and Z.
Then this is similarly defined where
omega R is just the product of all of
these other Omegas. So we defined Omega
Y up here, but you can just define this
for all of your other state spaces.
So now that we've done that,
we can continue our journey by going to
the tree. And so that's two steps away.
So all of the other things decrement two
and then an additional one. And then if
we go back to the house, that's four
time steps away plus the additional time
step of entering the house and getting
warm. Okay, so here
is another route you could take where
the hiker goes to the tree to eat and
then the hiker goes to the lake to
drink and then goes back to the
house to get warm. And so this JS
is a huge it's important to keep in mind
that JS is a huge operator and we cannot
explicitly form it in memory because
it's unless we have a lot of memory
on our computer. But having this
factorization allows us to chain
policies together and evolve a high
dimensional state vector in these jumps.
So we're jumping a state vector around
in this object oriented fashion where
each state vector is updated once
you get to some key object of interest,
such as the tree with the apple or the
lake with the water. So also
in this example, you can see that the
agent went from the lake to the house.
And technically, if z,
it occupies the lowest state, z zero.
And so technically it should die at the
skull and crossbones on the map, but we
let it finish his journey. And we
haven't talked about this sort of bi
directional coupling yet, but we'll do
that in the next slide to
make that concrete. All right,
so if we have these defective states,
we can define mode parameters e
plus and E minus, which are
just going to be variables that
condition our dynamics. And we can have
a mode function that takes any vector r
and R is any vector of blue, green and
red squares in the space, and we can map
it to a mode parameter. So we can define
zeta to map to the good mode,
the normal healthy mode, if it's
not occupying any of the defective
states. But if one or more defective
states are occupied, then we can map it
to E minus. And so that means if we have
some low level transition operator
that's indexed by E, that means we can
split it into a normal dynamics PE
plus and a defective dynamics PE minus.
And you just notice that the defective
dynamics is a sort of identity
operation. It just sort of arrests your
dynamics in the space so you can't move
around, but the normal dynamics is just
normal grid world movement.
Okay, what we
can do is we can compute a set
of individual feasibility functions for
each object of interest in the map. So
in the previous example, we had two
trees, two lakes and a house. So we have
five state time feasibility functions.
And then this Ada hat is an aggregate
function of all of these functions
where the pi is indexing the
corresponding pi for that function.
Anyone can ask questions, by the way,
if they have any questions.
All right,
so the full dynamics is
going to be just defined like we defined
it before, where we have
these two state spaces, the base state
space coupled to the internal state
space through F. But then we have this
zeta R here on the conditioning
side. And so this is an
operator that you
have to achieve goals in order to keep
yourself out of these sort of absorbing
defective states.
I showed this influence diagram before,
but this influence diagram is capturing
this coupling.
Okay, so many
of you will probably be familiar with
the standard Bellman equations which
are formalized this way, where you
have some reward function plus some
discounted expectation of your future
value. And so the value function in a
sort of standard Bellman equation says,
how much reward am I going to get if I
act here optimally over an infinite
horizon? And so the reward function is
often thought to be a task. It has that
sort of semantics in RL land.
And then the optimal policy is just
going to return the action that
corresponds to the best action that
maximizes your value, your long run
sum of rewards that you're going to get.
So this is a recursive equation,
but my
thesis is that we need to rethink
the sort of model based Bellman
formalizations in order to compute these
nice factorizations that move us around
high dimensional space like we've been
talking about on the previous slides.
So we're going to formalize some new
Bellman equations called operator
Bellman equations. And these are going
to be non stationary
Bellman equations or they're going to be
functions of time. So instead of having
a value function that says what's the
accumulated reward that I get? I'm going
to have a cumulative feasibility
function kappa. And this is going to
represent what is the cumulative
probability that I achieve a particular
goal, where a goal, remember, is an
action on a higher level space.
So this has a very similar form to the
infinite horizon Bellman equation that I
just showed. But you'll notice that we
have this availability function here for
a specific goal. So this is a single
goal G that we're picking out. So say
the eaten apple goal or the drink the
water goal. We're just choosing one.
And so F is returning
the availability of G from any given
state and time and action.
And then, so either the
agent achieves a goal now, which is what
this equation is saying, or which is the
plus the agent does not achieve the
goal. So one minus the probability of
achieving the goal is the probability
that you don't achieve the
goal times the expectation that you
achieve it in the future. So it has this
similar recursive structure that the
infinite horizon Bellman equation has.
Okay, so then we have the
policy, and this policy equation
is a little different from the last one
because you can imagine that you can
maximize the cumulative that you achieve
a goal, but you sort of do it at the
last second. You have maximized
certainty that you can get to the store
right before it closes. So you know
100% that you can achieve the goal of
getting an item from the store five
minutes before it closes. Well, it might
be if the store is open for some period
of time, that essentially
you might want to get it as soon as
possible. So what this equation is
saying is that we're going to pick the
action which maximizes the cumulative,
but from that set of equivalent actions
that maximize the cumulative, which is a
star. So we're collecting the actions
that maximize the cumulative and we're
going to pick the one that minimizes the
time. So this is the sort of conditional
optimization that says subject to the
fact that we want to maximize the
cumulative, we want to get there as fast
as we can normally
there's just with the infinite Horizon
Belmont equation, there's the value
function and the policy. Here we have a
third function, which is the
state time feasibility function which
I've been talking about. And the state
time feasibility function says given
that I start at X and T, what's the
probability that I achieve a goal g at
a particular state final state in time
XF and TF? And so you
can compute this via dynamic programming
as you're computing these other
functions. And there's
a relationship between the cumulative
feasibility and the state time
feasibility, which is that if you can
sum up the individual final states and
times from your state time feasibility
and that is the cumulative. So the
cumulative feasibility is just summing
over the individual probabilities of a
given state final state time.
And the nice property is that when
you use these operator bellman equations
on hierarchical state spaces, such as
the product space of the agent's
core ontology, it has a nice
decomposition property, which is that if
you're just solving to go to a
particular point in the world, then you
can actually compute Ada
separately from the high level space.
So you just solve for Ada the state time
feasibility function on the low level
space, but then omega can be computed
independently in the high level space
and they can be combined. So this
decomposition property is really nice
because we never want to work in a
product space, especially as we
learn tons of dynamics about how the
world works, we need to be able to
compute representations in a factorized
way which is going to help us move
around in reason. So this
means that when we compute a
bunch of individual state time
feasibility functions for each goal I
don't know why this little hat is here,
but then if we have
five of these and we have an aggregate
feasibility function. Then we can use
this aggregate feasibility function to
move around from
feature to feature in the low level
world and update all of our internal and
higher level states.
And so this is
the object from the previous slides that
sort of map us around the world. So you
can also do, and I won't talk about this
much, but you can also do logical tasks
where instead of eating an apple, you
might want to gather an apple. So if you
go obtain an apple, then there could be
a bit that corresponds to having an
apple. And you flip that bit to one once
you go to the tree and then you go
gather water at the lake and you flip
that bit and then you go to the
key and you obtain that key. And that
might be a task where you have to obtain
these three items, perhaps because you
wanted to compose this task with
something else. You want to bring these
items to another agent or whatever. So
the point is that you can use these
factorizations to move around the world,
especially when things in the world have
a sort of limited time period in which
they are available.
I talked about how we can plan in these
high dimensional state spaces using this
factorization. And now
we get to the question, well, why should
I plan to any particular high
dimensional state? That's the intrinsic
motivation question. Given that there's
an exponential number of state vectors
in a product space, why is one
state vector of the world in the far off
distance better than another? So that's
where empowerment comes in. Empowerment
is an intrinsic motivation metric
which sort of represents
controllability. So formally,
empowerment is a function of a
transition operator. It's an intrinsic
measure of a transition operator and
you can also condition it on the state
that an agent is at. So it takes two
arguments and it also has a horizon
n, which we'll talk about in a second.
So it's formally defined as the Shannon
channel capacity between your actuators
or sequences of actions that you take
and the resulting states. So the channel
capacity, so here open
loop sequence of actions would just be
go up right and up again, or up left and
then down.
There are a lot of possible sequences of
actions. So big a here is a random
variable for your sequences of actions.
And so for a horizon n, you can ask
how much information can we transmit
from our actuators to the resulting
state at time tau. So tau
minus T is our horizon n, which is this
parameter on the empowerment. So it's
just saying what's the agent's capacity
to affect the future with certainty
or varying amounts of certainty?
And so the channel capacity is formally
defined as the maximum mutual
information given distribution over
these action sequences and
the mutual information decomposes into
the entropy of the final states minus
the conditional entropy of the final
state random variable given that,
you know, given the actions and your
starting state. So this
means there are two sort of extremes
to empowerment. If PX is a deterministic
operator, so anytime I'm at state
X and I apply an action, I get a
deterministic output x prime,
then the conditional entropy,
there's going to be no uncertainty over
my future state. So the entropy is going
to be zero. There's no uncertainty. And
so that means that the conditional
entropy has to cancel out.
And so empowerment is really just the
maximum possible entropy given this
distribution. And this just reduces down
to the log of the number of possible
reachable states. So how much can I
actually reach in the world?
And so if my horizon is two, we can see
that the empowerment here is just log of
13. So there are 13 states I can get to,
and I have perfect control, so I can
actually realize any of those 13 states
if I want. And the other extreme
is, if PX is action independent,
meaning that any sort of state that I'm
in, I have an action, that maybe there's
the same distribution given that action,
say a uniform distribution,
then my
conditional entropy given the actions is
just going to be the entropy.
And so the empowerment has to be zero
because this term is going to cancel
out. And so there
might be a lot of states you can
technically reach because I can select
actions and I'm just going to go random
places. So Pink is all the states I
could possibly reach, but I don't have
any control over which state I'm going
to end up in. And so I can't influence
my future in any way,
even though there are a lot of possible
futures. So empowerment in that extreme
is zero. And then there's an in
between zone where you take actions and
there's a bias in one direction or
there's different distributions for each
action. And so there might be
uncertainty, but you can sort of control
how much information. You can sort of
control what state that you want to end
up at.
Okay, so what I'm going to define is
a function valence.
And it's important to note that
there's two arguments, the states, and
you can include the time too, and the
conditioning side. So you have
empowerment and
you can define an empowerment
difference. So say you start at S and T,
and then you end up at a
future state in time after you execute
some sequence of policies. So Row here
appended to the S and T is a sequence of
policies, and S row and T row are the
resulting states. Then you can compute
an empowerment difference. And this will
be our valence function. So Q here
is a function that I'll talk about in
just a second. But we can see that our
jump operator that's moving around high
dimensional space is defined
as this factorization. So we don't have
to represent it. Remember, that's an
important part. And so we. Can sample
multiple policies from this or chains of
policies. So if I have policy one,
policy two, then I'm going to have some
resulting state r double prime, x double
prime, TF two.
And so Q here can just represent the
output of chains of policies. So you can
imagine a tree search of chains
of policies, and Q is just summarizing
the final state of those branches in a
tree search of policies of chains of
policies. All right,
so we can use this Q.
So notice that this Q here is in the
expectation over here. So it's linking
our original state time to the final
state time. So it's the empowerment
after some chain of policies.
Okay,
so say we have a deterministic operator,
and this should be P,
then valence is an empowerment
difference. We can have a simple sort of
example here where we have two hikers
that are considering two different
plans. And so if this tree
here is like the space of two
possible chains of policies, then these
hikers are just executing one sort of
path through this tree.
They both have the same empowerment
because they're starting at the same
state and they're both two away
from starving. So if we just consider an
empowerment at the beginning, that's log
of 13, and if we chain
together two policies
here, we can advance our internal
state space and the agent will end up
down at the lake. And so given that
it's at the lake, you'll notice that
it's one state away from
dying, so that there's an effective
range of where it can
go. So the final empowerment is
log five, because there's five reachable
states and we're assuming determinism to
make this easy. So the valence
here, and this should be PS here,
but I have T here, but the valence is
just log five minus log 13.
And that's the difference between the
final and the initial. And so that has a
negative valence. The yellow
shirt hiker is clearly in a worse
position that he started off at.
But we can advance the other
hiker with pi g three to the
lake and then pi g four to the tree and
update his internal states.
And we can see that he's three away from
dying. So there's a bigger effective
range. And so there are 25 states that
he can get to.
Log of 25 minus log of 13 is
zero point 94, which means
that he's better off
than where he started. And so clearly,
the second hiker is executing a better
plan. He has more freedom to
engage with other tasks in the world.
And so if we searched
over this entire tree of policy chains,
we could pick the best one. And in this
example, we're just going to consider
two of these branches and we'd pick
policy pi g three,
pi g four. All right,
so there's also another interesting so
in this past example, we're just sort of
changing the structure we're just
changing the initial state. But since
empowerment is also a function of a
transition operator, and our operator
Bellman equations are producing
transition operators that map us from
state time to state time, then the
output of those Bellman equations, the
operator Bellman equations, produce
transition operators so we can compute
their empowerment. So that's
a deep connection between Bellman
equations and these intrinsic motivation
metrics. So we can do interesting
things where we can say, well, if the
structure of the world were different,
then the feasibility functions that I
could compute in different
configurations of the world would be
different. So if
the Honey Badger gets a key and it opens
a door in the mountain pass, then it
could potentially get through to the
other side. But it's important to note
that this is changing the structure
of the low level state space. So PE knot
is what we'll call the original
transition operator, in which we can't
go through the mountain pass. And that
means that if we compute state time
feasibility functions on this operator,
that means PE here is going into
the Bellman equation, then we're going
to produce state time feasibility
functions from those operator Bellman
equations. That's this object here,
which means that we can use it to
construct j to move us around high
dimensional space. And so there's an
empowerment for this j. But then if
we get the key and the key allows us to
move through the door, it changes the
structure of the world, then that's
a different mode of dynamics. So that
means that all of this applies on the
other side, where we can compute
feasibility functions off of a different
mode of dynamics in which we can move to
the mountain pass. And so that means we
can compute things,
we can compute valence by asking is this
configuration of the world more
conducive to the agent's core ontology
that is, the agent's internal external
coupling that needs to be maintained as
a sort of core object. And so
we can compute valence just by changing
j the structure of the agent's
abstractions that it moves to perform
tasks in the world. So by computing
empowerment on j, we're sort of
computing it in task space. We don't
have to consider all possible states of
the product space. We can narrow it down
to operators that move us around
task space, that induce dynamics on key
other state spaces that we care about
maintaining, such as our physiological
state spaces.
Okay, so here's a simple example. Say
the Honey Badger starts at the lake
and has some initial empowerment
just on the low level operator. So
that's P 50 there's
twelve states it can reach. But it also
has a task empowerment which is actually
zero because there's only one task that
it can engage in if you don't include
getting the key as a task. So the
circle here is saying that there's only
one sort of task that can be done. And
so if the agent goes and gets the key,
it's going to reduce its physiological
states because it had to travel there.
And then it gets the key and it
conditions a different mode of dynamics.
So there's different feasibility
functions associated with that mode
which I just described on the last
slide. Then the
door will open and it can travel back to
the lake. And so now that it's at the
lake, it can go eat food
on the other side, right? So before
getting the key, if it couldn't get the
key, if there were no key, then it would
just starve because while it could drink
water and stay hydrated, it couldn't eat
from the apple tree. But now it can
cycle back and forth between the apple
tree and the lake for as
long as it wants. And so it has
a higher empowerment just on the low
level state spaces, but it also has a
higher task empowerment because there
are just over a horizon of three and
we're just computing, we have to choose
a horizon. So the empowerment in task
space is eight because there's eight
possible branches in resolving states
from where it is. And so
that's very useful. So we
can compute the valence, which is
0.5 just in the low level space,
but also three in the task space.
And another interesting question which
is very important is to say, well,
what's the value of the key? And you can
compute this too. You can say, well,
given if I just fix the state vector
that I'm at, and I just alter the state
phi that encodes the
object of a key, if I just alter that
state and switch it between having a key
and not having a key, you can say,
well, this key has this much value to
the internal organization, the internal
integrity or controllability of the
agent. So it's a sort of agent centric
judgment of how much something in the
world is valuable. And so the key can be
not valuable if it doesn't do anything
in the world that helps the agent
control its core ontology.
So this is a way in which you can sort
of bootstrap value into the world.
You can use the change in an agent's
internal structure, its coupling between
the internal state spaces and the
external world. You can use the changes
in that structure to assign value to
things. And that's very useful.
Okay, I think we're approaching an hour.
And so I'll just conclude by saying
intelligent systems operate in high
dimensional product spaces, often with
non stationary dynamics. This introduces
a lot of problems, especially in
artificial intelligence because people
normally deal with structured tasks and
non stationary by training recurrent
neural networks and things like this,
which contribute a lot to sample
complexity. And what I'm saying is know
operator Bellman equations have this
different form which produces transition
operators, which helps you factorize
your representations for moving around
the world and predicting the resulting
high dimensional state vector.
And these operators are composable,
they compose with themselves, but they
also compose with higher level
structure. So you can remap different
transition structures to them. It's very
modular and these are very nice
properties that you need if
you don't want to recompute things and
you want to have sort of modular
structure come in and remap to your
representations that you've already so
forward sampling. Can you still hear me,
Daniel?
OK, just checking. So forward sampling
is a good way of solving problems in
high dimensional state spaces without
representing the product space. We can't
really solve, we can't do dynamic
programming in a huge product space
that's not going to work. We can't
sample low level actions, that's not
going to work, the tree is too
big. But we can work at the level
of sequences of policies and we
can evaluate empowerment gain to justify
our goal states. And so
Valence sort of unifies a lot
of distinct drives. Like there's a
different sort of subfield of RL called
multi objective reinforcement learning,
which says we'll have a bunch of
different reward functions and then
we'll have value functions for each of
these reward functions for different
tasks and that'll make like a high
dimensional value function vector space.
And usually in multi objective RL,
you have to pick a policy that that
does well in that value
function space, but normally you
have to deal with the trade offs by some
weighting function. So what I'm saying
here is that because valence
is just one number and it summarizes an
entire sort of control architecture,
that you don't have to introduce things
like weighting functions or weighting
coefficients to say, oh, this objective
is more important now, or this objective
is more important now.
So yeah, many latent drives is not
necessarily multi objective, it's
multidimensional, it's multi goal. But
it doesn't have to be multi objective
with empowerment. You don't have
weighted combinations of empowerment.
And valence depends on the
structure of the environment. So it's
not just some static property of the
world or a static property of an agent.
It incorporates agent world coupling.
And I thought I'd just end with this
quote from Terrence Deakin, who wrote a
great book called Incomplete Nature,
which I love and I read at the beginning
of Grad school, which inspired me a lot.
And Terrence Deakin wrote a lot about
teleology from a sort of thermodynamic
perspective and it's really compelling.
And I just liked what he had to say
about teleodynamics, the idea
that an organism could be, or its
behavior could be organized around
realizing something which is sort of
virtual. And he says Teleodynamics is
the dynamical realization of final
causality in which a given dynamical
organization exists because of the
consequences of its own continuous
continuance and therefore it can be
described as being self generating.
Specifically, it is the emergence of a
distinctive realm of orthograde dynamics
that is organized around a self
realizing potential, or to be somewhat
enigmatic, it is a consequence organized
dynamic that is its own consequence.
And I think that's relevant to what I'm
doing here because I think empowerment
sort of on an internal sort
of structured ontology, allows an agent
to say there are multiple, there's a
huge space of possible futures. But I
can evaluate a state of the world
that's far off in the distant
future, and I can organize all of my
behavior around that because I can say I
can give an explanation for why it
benefits my sort of core ontology.
And so therefore, it makes me capable
of acting that way in the future. It's a
consequence organized dynamic that is
its own consequence. So with that,
I just want to thank the Active
Inference Institute, and I will take
questions. And I'm very interested in
what active inference theorists think
about the sort of potential for a sort
of integrated view of empowerment,
because I think you all have a lot of
experience thinking about generative
models and things of that nature. So I'd
be very curious to know what you think.
Thank you.
Excellent. Thanks a lot.
Great presentation. So this will be a
fun discussion. Those who are watching
live, please feel free to add questions
in the live chat and you
can unshare your screen and we'll begin.
I guess I'll take an empowering deep
breath and ask a
general question, and then I have some
scattered notes that I'll love to dive
into. So how did you come to this area
of research? What brought you to control
theory modeling and to the empowerment
perspective specifically?
Hold on, I'm just bringing up the
YouTube stream so I can see comments
right now.
What brought just a general question.
Mute that one. There we go. Yeah, I'll
mute that sounds good. Thank you.
Yeah. So what brought me to empowerment?
I've always been interested in how
could animals interact
in a world in a way that's so sample
efficient, especially like, knowing that
animals can, like a baby horse
can get up and move around and interact
with the world in a sort of fluid,
flexible way. What are the sort of core
representational capacities that are
needed to do that? And I didn't really
see anything from the RL world, and this
is before I knew about active inference.
And so that's always been in the back of
my mind. And another big
influence was a guy named Nishith
Srivastava who wrote an interesting
paper about how you can basically
have a sort of relativistic decision
theory that allowed you to make
judgments between different items
without recourse to sort of hedonic
utility theory maximization. And so he
sort of argued that if there was
something like a latent acceptability
function, that you
could sort of remember a history of item
acceptability and you could remember the
context that you made decisions and that
you could actually just do Bayesian
inference over those memories. And you
could explain a lot of interesting
things like preference reversal
phenomena in decision theory where you
introduce irrelevant alternatives and it
changes the fundamental choice you make.
And I thought that sort of initiated a
lot of thinking into,
how could you bring those kinds of
intuitions into sort of embodied
planning? Like, how could it be that you
have an agent assign value to things
without them being sort of attributed as
sort of static
preferences or static utilities in the
world? So I think that was also a big
inspiration.
Awesome. Okay. And then one short
general question. Why the honey badger?
The honey badger? My advisor
showed me a YouTube video of
a honey badger named Staffel, and in my
paper, reward is not necessary.
The opening paragraph talks about
Stauffel, and there's a link to this
YouTube video. But Stauffel is a
honey badger in Australia, and he's
at some sort of animal care center, and
he's really good at escaping from
things. So the caretaker at
this animal sanctuary constantly has to
build elaborate structures to keep
staffel in. So he has this sort of pen
called badger alcatraz. And staffel
would do interesting things, know, find
objects to lean against the wall and
climb over. And if you took those away,
staffel would pack mud into
balls and stack them into, like, a
little pyramid against the wall to climb
up and things like that. So, yeah, it
got me thinking, what is a sort of good
general intrinsic motivation function
that doesn't just work on
low level states, but also in a
sort of more conceptual hierarchical
space? Like there might be objects or
mating opportunities or anything sort of
outside badger alcatraz? What is the
sort of way in which you could have an
agent sort of think in a sort of
abstract way in order to justify
its motivations?
So I encourage the listeners to
look up that video. It's entertaining.
It's like this general escape impulse
yes. Extended into our open
air context, where we also
want to maintain the ability to move.
And for mobile creatures,
that's quite a good proxy for what we
might want to care about, like living.
Right. All right. I'll go to a question
in the chat from Alex Kiefer.
Fantastic work. Maybe a naive question,
and I'm sure it's clear in the
formalism, which I have only begun to
look at, but the idea is that actual
agent environment coupling figures in
computing empowerment, right? If so, is
there a fully internal proxy that can be
optimized given information available
internally?
Is there let's see.
Is there a fully internal proxy that can
be computed that can be optimized given
info available internally
and not part of the coupling? Does he
mean,
I suppose you could compute empowerment
just on the internal state space,
but I don't know. Actually, I kind of
want to say no, just because you do need
to use actions to move around
and influence other state spaces and
things like this. I don't know how I
would compute just
a sort of internal intrinsic motivation
function that isn't a part of some
coupling to some broader system.
What about the desire to think freely
and to move in cognitive spaces broadly?
Yeah, I agree. Okay, so yeah,
I definitely agree. If you have all of
your sort of physiological needs met
and they aren't sort of imposing
themselves on you, you're sort of freed
up to do other things. Right? So yeah,
I think that this could work generally
into very abstract spaces, maybe even
mathematical spaces and
yeah, I think that there can be higher
level dependency structures in abstract
thought or mathematical thought or
things like this. I mean, you think
about faulty proofs that sort
of like destroy an entire field or
something. There is a sort of dependency
structure in which that
if you're working on mathematics that
assume some proof is true and it turns
out to be false, then perhaps that's
disempowering from a sort of abstract
perspective. I suppose so that would be
yeah,
good, I was just going to say but again,
all that mathematics is being done by
some system that has to perform
computation which takes energy and stuff
like that. So it's always sort of
constrained by that,
constrained by some kind of external
internal coupling.
Many ways to go let's swerve towards
active inference and then see if we can
come back to some other areas.
You mentioned the generative model of
active inference but you took a
different approach there's, different
model ontology. So just broadly, how
would you structurally contrast the
coupling of the agent and the
environment in active inference and in
what you've proposed? Because the
representations that we see in active
inference often feature the particular
partitioning where a Markov blanket of a
Bayesian graph is intermediating between
internal and external states and then
there's a mapping function between those
internal and external. States such that
they can engage in an adaptive coupling,
again mediated through the blanket,
which is interpreted as providing
incoming sensory observations and
outgoing actions. So structurally, is
that compatible, incompatible or some
other secret third thing with what you
proposed? Yeah, so I would start
off by saying that I think the thing
that makes my work different is
that it's the structure of the latent
sort of discrete state space. It's that
structure that's under consideration
and I think that in active inference
usually encode things like homeostatic
drives. Right? You encode them in a
generative model right, correct. They
are encoded as a preference over sensory
observations so that the entity seeks
out and selects ultimately policies that
reduce or bound their surprise about
those observations. Like I expect and
prefer myself to be at a homeostatic
temperature. I'm not surprised when I'm
in that range and I'm going to undergo
actions so that I find myself in that
range. Yeah, so I would say that
that is a major difference because the
state space in my case has this sort of
self undermining quality where it's like
bad starvation states.
It's not really a surprise, an
expectation of receiving a particular
signal or having a preference over some
state of the world. It has a sort of
self undermining quality that affects
your ability to control everything else.
So I think
I would contrast it that way that
usually the preferences or the quality
of the states are sort of encoded in a
generative model in the active inference
setting. And here I'm saying that
there's a sort of structural coupling
that's giving rise to these valence
signals. MMM.
You mentioned the key being obtained as
inducing this change in the agent's
ontology and one that was ultimately
reflected by increase in empowerment,
hence increase in valence. So how does
it come to understand that this
shiny object unlocks that door?
Yeah, I think
that throughout my career
I will try to make steps towards
actually figuring that out because a lot
of this comes down to dynamics learning.
If an agent doesn't know what a key
does, right, it's not going to know that
it opens a door and therefore that it
can move through the door and things
like this. I think there are a lot of
sort of maybe like Dyna like
algorithms in which you sort of
alternate between learning things
about dynamics or things like this. But
that is a sort of outstanding question
for me, is like, yeah, how would you
take a key and learn exactly how it's
changing the dynamics?
But yeah, what I am saying is that given
that you can do that, if you can do
that, then you can really sort of make
these value judgments to things in the
world. So I think that's really
important too, because consider money,
right? Like, if I find a $20 bill on the
ground, I'm just going to pick it up. I
don't think I'm doing a fancy
computation, right, of like, oh,
now my bank account is $20 greater
and so therefore I have all this new
capacity or things like this. I think
these sort of preferences for various
objects like a key or a dollar bill or
things like this can sort of be
stored and maybe models
with utility theory, who knows?
Okay, jumping around to some different
questions. I hope I'm accurate in saying
you described empowerment as a Shannon
information theoretic channel capacity
between the actuators and the
realization of the state. We might be
familiar with hearing Shannon channel
capacity in the context of bandwidth of
information transfer or upload and
download, for example. But this is kind
of an action oriented Shannon channel
capacity. So what does it mean to
get an intuition on that capacity
between the actuators and the state?
Yeah, so the channel capacity is the
maximum possible mutual information
between the actions you choose and the
resulting states. So the channel
capacity is sort of the maximum
information that you can transmit from
your actuators to possible states of the
world. It's a form of optionality
that says I can affect this many sort
of possible futures. So, yeah, it's a
sort of intrinsic property of an agent.
And so in a product space, this is going
to be affected by a lot of different
state spaces. If they're interacting,
like physiological, state spaces can
kill you if they get too low. So I
think the interesting thing about this
is that it sort of encourages you to
think about cognition in
this sort of interrogative way because
you're essentially trying to figure out
what you can do. But there are a lot of,
you know, different state spaces that
are hindering that information transfer
from your actuators to your state
spaces. So I think it's very useful
because it
also sort of leads to explainable AI,
right? You can sort of explain your
intentions in terms of concrete state
spaces which which have structure and
explanation, things like that. I think I
got off topic from your question, but
anything else on Shannon channel
capacity that I should talk about?
I think, before we loop it back to
potentially expected free energy. You
mentioned the AI topic,
and is there any risk of
an imperative that features its
own empowerment in
terms of an AI being able to then select
action policies that might not be what
anyone else expects or prefers, may not
even be concordant with their own
encoded explainable AI priors, but
rather something that takes an
unbounding approach?
Yeah, I do think that that is a fear.
I haven't thought that much about the
alignment question, so I'd be very
interested in what alignment researchers
think of this perspective. I think that
there's a lot of interesting work to do
on sort of multi agent empowerment,
especially with these sort of abstract
transition operators that work on long
time scales and you
can see that how sort of socialization
matters and things like this. If you're
in a world with multiple agents,
do you have to learn to respect all of
the agents empowerment? I mean, they can
also act against you, right?
So? Yeah. I don't know. I do think it's
a fear to take seriously.
I don't know how I would do it though,
because it's an outstanding research
question to me. Coming from an ant
colony background, you mentioned the
socialization and I immediately thought,
well, let's just say that the seeds take
two or three nest mates to carry home.
So in order to have one nest mate
achieve the maximum empowerment, they
must also engage in a pro social
environment. Because if anyone else,
even if their model is smaller and less
empowered, if they just decide not to
play, then that individual until it
figures out how to carry the seed home
alone is going to actually be kind of
tethered to a social fabric that
helps it actually obtain those goals.
So it puts the social imperative as
a screen in front of potentially any
other imperative. Just a thought.
Yeah, that's a great thought.
You mentioned the decomposition of some
function. I'll let you unpack exactly
what function was being decomposed and
you justified that by saying we never
want to work in the product space from
a computational complexity perspective
or however makes sense. What are the
dangers or what are the scaling features
of that product space and then what is
the decomposition that facilitates a
more tractable form? Yeah, I'll share
my screen again. We can go back to that
slide. Thank you.
Let's see,
here it is.
You can see my screen. Yep. And maybe
even a brief summary of what is a
Bellman equation and how did you move
from the standard formalization of
Bellman equations into this operator
space? Sure, yeah. The standard
Bellman equation,
I don't know the button for one slide
forward. Okay, so the standard Bellman
equation just has this recursive
form and it's just the value of
a state that you're at. The optimal
value of that state is the
maximum value that you can get by
choosing an action that rewards you and
takes you to a state from which you can
act in the future to get more reward.
So the Bellman equation can
be solved by dynamic programming in
order to maximize this function V.
So it'll result in a policy that moves
you around the world in a way that
accumulates a reward that you'll find in
your environment. So it has this
recursive form. You can sort of unroll
it into a sequence and then the
operator Bellman equation has this
similar recursive form where now
you'll notice that there isn't a reward
function. There's this availability
function and it returns a number between
zero and one. It returns a probability.
And so that's significant because it
means that you can maximize the
cumulative feasibility. And so
F here is just saying this goal is
available. Either you achieve the goal
now or you take an action. You don't
achieve it now, but you take an action
in which you'll achieve it in the
future. So it
has the same form where you can sort of
think of an availability function as a
reward, but it's maintaining a
probabilistic form. And that
probabilistic form is important because
it's what allows you to compute the
state time feasibility as a transition
operator, as an operator that maps you
from where you are now, the state time
you're at now, which is XT, to the final
state time and goal that you achieve.
So under the policy, so it says if I
start at XT and I follow this policy and
I'm choosing actions that move me
through this state space, then I'm
eventually going to get to the goal and
I want to know the final state in time,
the probability that I achieved this at
any given state in time. And so the
state time feasibility function is here.
As it's expressed is a transition
operator with one action, which is the
policy. But when we aggregate it I'll
bring this up. When we aggregate it into
multiple possible feasibility functions
that are centered around multiple sort
of objects in the world, then all of the
policies associated with each one of
those these are goal condition policies
that are going to terminate on achieving
the goal of going to one of these
features and getting the apple, for
instance. Then each of those policies is
an action for this transition operator.
So there's five possible policies that
are going to take you around the space.
So these operator Bellman equations have
this probabilistic form which retain
this probabilistic structure. And you
can sort of compare this with I don't
know if you're familiar, but there's
this concept in RL called the successor
representation which is often
a hot topic in computational
neuroscience. And the successor
representation is sort of talked about
like it's this predictive operator. But
really what it represents is expected
state Occupancies under a policy and
those expected state Occupancies are
weighted by the discount factor. So a
successor representation is really a
sort of weighted statistic and it
doesn't map from like an initial state
to the state of inducing
an event of achieving a goal where
successor representations aren't
compositional. You can't multiply two
successor representations and get
another successor representation. Well,
you can multiply matrices that represent
state time feasibility functions because
they're mapping their probabilities of
events. So you can combine them just by
multiplying matrices that represent the
state time feasibility function for a
given policy with another one for a
different policy. So that will retain
the form of a probabilistic function and
that's what makes them reusable
composable, et cetera. And I think you
asked me about the decomposition and
this decomposition. Yeah, I might have
glossed over this. But the decomposition
result is that if you were to compute
a state time feasibility function in a
product space which has lots
of state vectors which are each states,
then you don't want to do that because
product spaces are very large and take a
lot of memory to represent the operator.
So if this was not PX and this was PS,
and PS was the full product space
operator that moves you around this high
dimensional space, well, you can't
really represent that and you don't
really want to. But if you did and you
computed a state time feasibility
function in a product space, then you
can under certain conditions and I
can say what those conditions are, but
under certain conditions you can
decompose this into a prediction
of all of the higher level state spaces
computed independently. So you evolve
the hunger space separately and you
evolve the thirst space separately and
you evolve the temperature space
separately. You can do all of those
computations locally on those spaces and
you can combine them with a state time
feasibility function that's only
computed on the low level space.
So this hierarchical state time
feasibility function is an intractable
object for most reasonably sized
problems, but you can implicitly form
it by this product of these things
individually. And so this works when
your goal for the
hierarchical state time feasibility
function, when you just have a single
goal at arriving at a particular feature
of the world like a tree,
that's one of the conditions in which
this decomposition holds. So I think
that answered your question about the
burden of a product space. Well,
you need to overcome it by doing local
computations on individual state spaces
in a sort of network of interconnected
state spaces that implicitly form a
product space. But you want to compute
all of the representations separately in
this network of state spaces so that you
can sort of move around this high
dimensional state space under successive
policies. And so that's
what allows you to handle forward
sampling in this high dimensional state
space. And that's important because
I think just to recall
the sort of presentation, I think it
was aval A-V-E-L yes, the French.
Gwen Carlo yeah, just to echo
that sort of sentiment, that if
you're creating new state spaces or
you're composing, you're not computing
policies in a fixed world,
you're composing things together,
that's of course, going to expand the
product space implicitly of all the
state vectors of the system. And the
act of composing or bringing new
information in is expanding the implicit
product space that you are in.
And so from an RL standpoint,
it's not so clear what a reward function
on that product space is even supposed
to be. I don't think that anyone will
answer that question. But it's also not
clear what a generative model
should look like on that product space
either. And I think given that humans
at least are so skilled at
this sort of dialectical process of
proposing theories and composing
structure as hypotheses and
interrogating what that means,
I think that value comes from
interrogating what it means for
the structure of the world to be a
certain way. So if I learn new dynamics
of the world and I want to control
dynamics on some new space, it might
affect other state spaces. But from
a normative perspective, it's not really
clear. Once you compose something and
you're expanding the implicit product
space, it's not so clear where any sort
of source of normativity should come
from. But I think the sort of flexible
human reasoning that we sort of know
humans to engage in, I think, is in this
sort of regime of composition and
interrogation where you're always sort
of saying, oh, if the world were this
way, then I
could see how this state space affects
these other state spaces in a way that I
didn't anticipate. And so I think
normativity in a creative way has to
come from controllability. That would be
my argument.
There's a lot there. So a few
directions first to our colleagues in
reinforcement learning. RL, the paper is
provocative in that it includes reward
is not necessary. So is reward
sufficient and or what is necessary
for what?
Yeah, it's a good question. Is reward
sufficient?
I would argue this I
think that the reward enough hypothesis,
which just to remind some of the viewers
is the hypothesis that reward
maximization can account for all
sort of artificial and sort of natural
intelligence. That all of the sort of
features of intelligence, the sort of
capabilities, the structure,
learning and stuff can all sort of arise
out of some need to some process
of maximizing reward. And from my
standpoint that's a frustrating
statement because one, it doesn't
one it doesn't really address where
your preferences for specific reward
functions come from. And in the paper
they will say well, we acknowledge that
there could be multiple sources of
reward but the process
of deciding on what reward you should
attend to or care about that I think
deciding what signals you should care
about is an important part of
intelligence itself and I think that
reward is enough. Hypothesis as a
hypothesis is sort of under constrained
in that whatever that mechanism is to
that perspective it's going to be
maximizing reward under their paradigm.
And so therefore whatever
shapes what that mechanism is that an
agent should attend to this or an agent
should stop attending to the things
that's always cared about and attend to
some new signal.
I think that that forces you to sort of
take the position that maybe there's,
like, a meta reward that directs this
process because all sort of attendant
processes of intelligent systems sort of
underlie the process of reward.
Maximization and also the
reward is enough. Hypothesis is
not being specific about it
doesn't tell you what necessarily to
compute. It just says that if you try to
maximize reward,
you will compute the right
representations. And so I think that
there's just a lot of nuts and bolts
about what it takes to be able to reason
in a flexible human way. And what I'm
proposing here with the operator Bellman
equations is to say hey, look, there's
these reward free Bellman equations that
help you deal with the complexity of the
world, there's no reward in them. And
you could make the case, well, maybe you
could just use these operator Bellman
equations to occupy states that are
rewarding. But I would argue that since
the effective product space that we all
live in is so vast and we reason about
it in such a flexible way, I very much
doubt that RL will rise to the challenge
of being able to justify motivations in
real time in a way that humans can. And
so to get to the question of is it
sufficient, my hunch is no,
I don't have a proof of reward is not
sufficient. But I also
think that the information that a reward
function is supposed to carry about what
is good. I don't think that is
noble or computable on the timescales
that we understand human intelligence to
work at, to work on. And so,
yeah, in order to answer your question
about what is necessary, I don't know
what is necessary, but I would just
sort of make the point I already made of
that. I think that we have to get to
a point in which we sort of acknowledge
the problems of product spaces and sort
of reasoning dialectically in a product
space that we can't explicitly
represent. And so I
don't know what is necessary, but I can
say that it's not necessary for simple
self preserving agents. And that's the
claim of the paper. Awesome.
All right. In our closing segments,
I'd like to take a journey to philosophy
and then connect this back to
potentially relationships between
the models that you've presented here
and active inference and maybe even walk
to the edge of that cliff of the hybrid
model. So Aristotle proposed
four causes material cause,
what something is made of the efficient
cause, which is the source of change.
The formal cause is the essence, and the
final cause is the teleology,
the end goal of the object.
And your presentations TeLEOS
was Deacon's analysis of these
different forms of teleology.
And indeed, within the model proposed
empowerment was that type of
self referential teleology.
When juxtaposing with active inference,
and specifically the expected free
energy functional, which has a lot of
analogies with an operator, it's a
function of other functions. The
expected free energy functional is
predicated around helping the agent
select policies that over
expected futures, reduce their
uncertainty the most about which
sensations they receive. And that's what
ties active inference closely with
perceptual control theory that that
expected free energy is ultimately
looking at a divergence between
preferences over observations and
incoming observations. So that's kind of
the sense side of the coin. It's like,
I want to stay in the game to be able to
align observations with my preferences.
And I'm wondering if empowerment
is the action side of the game. I agree.
Saying you'll be involved with,
yes, repeatedly sensing yourself to not
be starving, not be dying of thirst,
not be dying of cold. You'll be in your
preference vector by way
of this single value,
which is the empowerment. Whereas active
inference kind of comes from the other
side saying, you're going to end up
having a lot of squares to move around
in, but first you need to make sure that
you're reducing divergence between your
preferences and your expected
observations. Mmhmm.
What do you think about that map? Or
where would that take these intertwined
models? Well, I think that
there could be, like, an interface
between the two concepts. If we consider
that models of how things work, like
composed models of how things work,
could induce particular generative
models that you would want to use in
a sort of active inference setting. And
that would be the sort of dual nature
between the two that there's a cross
talk between the proposal of
some kind of generative model that would
be conducive to the agent. And if
it is, then it could be a good state
encoding which feeds back in on
controllability or empowerment and
things like this. So, I mean, there's a
lot to think about on this topic,
but I guess I would just put it that
way, that we still need
to justify where
generative models come from in new
situations, for new theories of how
things work and things like that. And
there could be a dual process in which
the action side, the internal
controllability side is dictating what
kinds of generative models that should
be considered.
Very interesting.
And the reason I brought up Aristotle's
causes was because active inference as
a process theory seems to be describing
that efficient cause. It's just
especially with a variational free
energy, which is kind of the real time
version of the expected free energy.
It's like one step at a time ball
going downhill. And so variational
inference is enabling incremental,
unfolding optimization, again oriented
around reducing that sensory preference
and outcome.
It does everything but specify
a final cause. In a sense, one might
say that there's a local final cause
within the active inference generative
model, which is like to reduce the
divergence between the preferences and
the observations. But the generative
model also from
the action selection side, which is what
makes active inference active inference.
It also needs a final cause in
that self referential teleodynamic
way. And so there could be some very
interesting architectures where
active inference picks up,
where empowerment leads,
like through a needle, because it's
such a small representation with
valence. And then one other kind of
connection or maybe mapping between them
is we've seen models of valence in
active inference, such as the affective
inference work, where valence
was associated broadly with whether
things are going better or worse than
expected. In terms of statistical
uncertainty, if you're reducing your
uncertainty more than you expected,
things are going better than expected
and vice versa.
So that is a very variance
oriented valence
concept where broader
uncertainties are associated with
inferior valence and tighter
positive valence. And it's just
interesting that that's kind of like an
orthogonal valence concept from how
much you can actually do that's the
actionable valence. Would you rather
have a high precision around not
being able to do anything, or high
uncertainty about being able to do a
lot or a huge amount?
And so it almost seems like when we
contrast those two, the direction that
dominates is, in the
final analysis, the ability to have
empowerment, not necessarily to just
have tight control over your
observations.
Yeah, I agree.
Lots of interesting avenues for hybrid
theories.
Well, what a very interesting talk.
I guess one more question on the model
and then we'll close, which is the time
horizon is it an infinite time horizon,
or what is the treatment
of time? And can time be continuous, or
is time always discrete, and is it
finite or infinite?
A so the operator Bellman equations are
formalized as a finite horizon. I
suppose they could be extended to
infinite horizon and infinite or
continuous time. I suppose that's
possible too. But as they're formalized
now, it's discrete state, discrete time,
finite horizon.
But yeah, I think that there's
alternative forms that could be made.
Was there another question too, in it?
Can't remember.
Let us close with your time horizon.
What are your next steps with the
research, and how would you imagine an
ecosystem of continuation of the work?
Yeah, I'm interested in getting this
work into computational neuroscience
problem, because there's a lot of,
I think, alternative models that need to
be considered, especially given some of
the themes that I've touched on in terms
of justifying what to do in a product
space, how do you represent control
in a distributed system, et cetera.
And so I think that there's a lot to do
there in computational neuroscience. On
the AI side, I want to put this in a
world model. I want to
get good auto encoders,
kind of like how I had on the first
slide, where you have a high dimensional
agent in a high dimensional multimodal
world, how do you have nice world models
and put this in something like that?
So that's the AI future direction, and
I'd like to do both of them. So I have a
lot of work to do. Awesome. Well,
in closing, I'm just going to read some
of the more statement like comments from
the live chat, just so that they're
included in the Active inference
journal. So Dave Douglas wrote with
regards to Deacon's consequence,
galileo may have gotten in trouble less
from insisting on a heliocentric
universe than from insisting that
purpose, value, and meaning be banished
from science as connecting explanatory
principles. The Galileo tolerated
remaining connecting principle,
causation may have reached the limits of
its explanatory power sometime between
Newton's and Fourier's day, where all
respectable principles of explanation
must ultimately rest on invocation of
either rigid rods or on elastic bands.
The Galilean program of Sola Casa
attained its absurdity in Carnap's
insistence that meaning, value,
counterfactuals must be judged as
strictly and literally as meaningless.
Have we passed the point when the
Galilean program must be simply
abandoned, and meaning, value, and
purpose must be restored to science as
irreducible explanatory principles?
Alongside Causation, I find the
mysticisms of both Bohm and Heisenberg's
quantum completeness and of Powelly and
Jung's synchronicity to just be too
fluffy to be very useful. In a word, it
has become a tradition of science as
funded to insist that Causation, and
Causation alone, must found our
enterprise. This is a tradition of men,
not a feature of ultimate reality.
Meaning and value also have their place
not reducible to cause.
I like it. Yeah. Excellent. Well,
Thomas, thank you again for joining.
You're always welcome back and really
looking forward to seeing how this all
continues. Me too. And thanks
again for having me. I've been very
impressed with how much work you do for
the discord, and it's a great community.
Everyone's very nice and enthusiastic,
so I was excited to see it. I just sort
of randomly stumbled across it. So I'm
glad I introduced myself to the discord.
So thank you. Excellent. All right,
till next time. Thank you. Great. Thank
you.